[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
litres d'eau 26 minutes pour revenir sur
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines
au sommaire ce vendredi 17 janvier pôle
emploi au courage la mixité
professionnelle pour cela des femmes en
recherche d'emploi sont conviés dans les
yvelines
à découvrir le métier de conductrice de
bus les plus convaincus bénéficieront
d'une formation puis d'une embauche dans
les transports geste fort de la part de
1200 médecins hospitaliers la démission
de leurs fonctions administratives en
début de semaine les adresser une lettre
à la ministre de la santé relayée dans
les colonnes de libération
nous ferons le point avec l'un des
signataires chef de service à l'hôpital
mignot que tu généraux concours le
département des yvelines en colère après
la société calcia mobilisation toujours
contre la réforme des retraites et carte
du rer vélo dévoilé pour reviendront sur
les temps forts de la semaine en et
avant de commencer cette édition cette
bonne nouvelle l'open de france de golf
2020 se jouera au golf national c'est
une information tv 60,18 le partenariat
et même renouvelé pour trois ans il
était question d'une délocalisation avec
le var en tête mais c'est bien à 50 ans
du lean que le plus vieux tournoi
d'europe continentale se tiendra du 2 au
5 juillet prochain le tour européen
devrait officialiser cette information
avant la fin du mois de janvier
[Musique]
dans son programme de mixité
professionnelle pôle emploi et ses
partenaires proposent une formation pour
devenir conductrice seize femmes peuvent
suivre ce tout premier programme avec
potentiellement un cdi à la clé
les intéressés avaient rendez vous mardi
au pôle emploi de guyancourt reportages
réalisés avec lise et lan valin journée
d'information pour cette trentaine de
femmes en recherche d'emploi dans le
cadre de son programme de mixité
professionnelle pour l'emploi leur
propose de découvrir le métier de
conductrice de bus base de la mixité
professionnelle c'est aujourd'hui
orientée des femmes sur des métiers
d'hommes ou des hommes sur des métiers
de femmes c'est trouver justement cette
fameuse parité sur certains secteurs qui
sont en difficulté et amener des
compétences vers des métiers justement
qui en ont besoin
les plus intéressés ont ensuite pu
participer un job dating avec les quatre
entreprises partenaires seize d'entre
elles seront retenues après validation
de leur motivation par un test théorique
et pratique suivie de trois jours
d'insertion professionnelle au sein des
entreprises
elles bénéficieront de trois mois de
formation financée par pôle emploi et
ses partenaires vous rendez compte j'ai
45 ans j'en ai encore pour 25 ans de
travail c'est à dire qu'une fois que je
signe c'est jusqu'à la retraite
et j'aurais pas de souci de chercher du
boulot ailleurs ou de crise parce que
dans le transport il ya toujours du
travail donc c'est vraiment
on comptera sur quoi une aubaine pour
les quatre entreprises présentes le
transport est actuellement en manque de
conducteurs et conductrices
c'est un vivier intéressant ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de retrouver des gens
qu'ils soient motivés par ce métier là
la découverte de ce métier la
valorisation de ce métier et la mixité
est quelque chose d'hyper important
c'est une politique d'entreprise
donc on a espoir de trouver des gens
motivés intéressant objectif pour cette
entreprise embauche et ces femmes à la
sortie de leur formation
généralement en cdi pour 1800 euros
bruts sur un contrat de 35 heures
[Musique]
le cauchemar il a commencé quand on a
commencé à nous dire va falloir que vous
produisez du séjour
alors que nous on avait l'habitude de
prodiguer des choix c'était en début de
semaine 1200 médecins adressé une lettre
à la ministre de la santé agnès buzyn
dans laquelle il indiquait démissionner
de leurs fonctions administratives si
celle-ci n'engageait pas ne s'engageait
pas à les recevoir en vue des
négociations sur l'avenir de l'hôpital
un mouvement porté par le collectif
inter hôpitaux au crayon septembre
qu'estime le plan d'urgence annoncé le
20 novembre
insuffisant une délégation est reçue par
la ministre de la santé
à l'heure où nous enregistrons cette
émission philippe rousselot vous êtes
avec nous bonjour jours alors vous êtes
chef de service hématologie oncologie au
centre hospitalier de versailles
andré mignot et cd rocancourt et vous
avez signé cette lettre tout d'abord que
veut dire démissionné de ses fonctions
administratives
alors c'est une démission qui ne
concerne que la partie de gestion des
services
ça ne concerne pas la partie de soins
soit crois qu'il faut que tout le monde
est bien en tête que le soin sera
assurée un n'ai jamais été question pour
les soignants de faire des grèves de
soins ni les fonctions de recherche et
d'enseignement puisque on accueille
beaucoup d'étudiants aussi au sein de
l'hôpital mignot est généralement dans
les services hospitaliers
donc les la grève administrative quelque
part parce que finalement l'admission
illustratif c'est un peu la grève
administrative c'est ne plus siéger dans
certaines instances
laissez de côté les injonctions sur des
objectifs budgétaires sur des feuilles
excel qu'il faut remplir le dialogue
avec la direction et la structure
narrative l'hôpital peut en être
ralentie mais c'est une façon je crois
de rester visible et mobiliser ou au
sein du collectif inter hôpitaux
l'objectif étant quand même de porter
les revendications de ce collectif
justement quelles sont ce qu'elles sont
elles ces revendications a qui vont être
échangés avec la ministre alors il ya
trois points principaux le premier point
c'est un problème lié à la
revalorisation des métiers hospitalier
et quand je dis ça je pense plus
d'ailleurs aux soignants infirmières
aides soignantes manipulateurs radio et
tous les métiers qui font le soin à
l'hôpital
bon on dit souvent comme éléments de
langage que les salaires des infirmières
sont dans les plus bas des pays ocde
mais il voudrait cette réalité et je
pense que ça doit être corrigé la
deuxième revendication à côté de ces
revendications d'attractivité ses
revendications sur le niveau de
financement de l'hôpital dans sa
globalité avec l'hôpital il fonctionne à
l'activité maintenant avec la fameuse
t2a donc plus des deux tiers des budgets
hospitaliers sont liés à l'activité
alors tu es déjà ça veut dire
tarification à l'activité
donc c'est l'acronyme effectivement et
cette fameuse t2a et la façon dont
l'hôpital peut obtenir son budget au fur
et à mesure que l'activité dans
l'hôpital se fait et cette tarification
des séjours même si elle a pu avoir
certains aspect bénéfique en termes de
réorganisation de restructuration on en
voit maintenant la limite et étant donné
que la dotation globale est toujours
contrainte qu'elle diminue avec le temps
on voit maintenant une course à
l'activité qui est à mon avis est de
l'avis du cih qui n'est plus bénéfique
aux patients et qui ne passent plus par
des restructurations on va dire ce n est
nécessaire donc ce travail-là a été fait
et le système arrive d'un petit peu à sa
limite sur ce type de tarification dont
on demande ça on demande que le budget
global de l'hôpital soit revalorisé
il a baissé de façon constante sur les
dix dernières années donc il a besoin
d'être valorisés et enfin les hôpitaux
se sont endettés pour se moderniser et
ce poids de le poids de cette dette pèse
beaucoup sur les comptes des hôpitaux
ils empêchent d'innover donc ça le le
rachat de la dette est aussi une des
revendications et donc la d re le
dernier volet c'est un volet de
gouvernance puisque la loi qu'on appelle
hpst donc et la loi qui nous régit l
heure actuelle a mis le directeur de
l'hôpital au centre de toute la
gouvernance de l'hôpital et on souhaite
que cette gouvernance redeviennent
quelque chose de plus partagés entre le
monde médical et soignant et
la direction d'hôpital alors on l'a dit
le 20 novembre la ministre de la santé a
annoncé un plan d'urgence suite aux
premières mobilisations septembre avec
notamment des accompagnements financiers
c'est pas suffisant
c'est sûrement pas suffisant vu le
retard qui a été pris c'est déjà
significatif je crois que personne ne
dit que ce qui a été proposé dans les
amendements du plan pour ma santé 2020
n'est pas s'il n'est pas significatif
mais mais ça va être insuffisant par
exemple pour revaloriser les métiers
soignants propose des primes une déprime
les plus importantes pour l'île de
france c'est une prime d'exercice en
milieu comptera sur le plan immobilier
transports etc
et bien cette prime est de toucher que
les soignants les infirmières de paris
intra muros et de petite couronne
donc si on prend l'exemple par exemple
de l'autre cas de mignot dans les
yvelines
eh bien les soignants de cet hôpital ne
toucheront pas la prime par exemple
justement vous voulez venir à cet
hôpital mignot vous travaillez vous êtes
même vice président de la commission
médicale établissements quelle est la
situation actuelle
ce centre hospitalier de versailles
alors se trouve ça versailles reste un
centre hospitalier qui globalement se
porte plutôt bien qui a un centre
hospitalier qui a toujours été portée
pour répondre aux besoins de santé de
son territoire et qui a été supporté sur
l'innovation la médecine de spécialité
pour autant si on fait un constat de
façon très globale un petit peu une
photographie nous on en est par exemple
des recrutements on s'aperçoit avec un
peu de surprises que on est en déficit
de recrutement médical soit à peu près
l'équivalent d'une quarantaine de postes
on est en déficit de recrutement para
médical et infirmier sur à peu près
l'équivalent de 70 postes
et puis on est en déficit de recrutement
sur des métiers
techniques comme les manipulateurs radio
et c'est à peu près sur une 30 40 postes
donc il ya globalement à l'hôpital
mignot pas loin de 150 postes qui sont
vacants alors on vous dira oui mais 150
postes vacants dans un hôpital
c'est logique il ya un turnover des
personnels etc
mais la difficulté qu'on commence à
traverser c'est que ces postes restent
vacants c'est à dire que ils sont certes
vacants mais on a pu les candidats qu'on
avait auparavant pour qui est ce
renouvellement du personnel qui est
nécessaire et qui est habituel hôpital
donc 20 ans craig concrètes ça peut
amener ça amène par une plus au service
de réanimation à fermer des lits de
réanimation 1 par manque d'infirmières
de réanimation ça amène le service
d'imagerie à réduire et vacations de
scanner par manque de manipulateurs
radio et ses candidats qui ont disparu
sont passés où ils vont vers le privé
alors je sais pas si on peut dire que
tous les candidats vont vers le privé
il y à aussi à un petit peu un manque de
nombre de personnes qui vont dans ces
formations
lorsque mais ça traduit un manque
d'attractivité globale des métiers
soignants et l'hôpital public est plus
touché par ça parce qu'effectivement les
niveaux de rémunération à l'embauché
sont inférieurs s'ils ont conclu un peu
qu'est ce que vous attendez pour
l'hôpital mignon à l'avenir ba pourrait
être tel mignot je pense qu'on a fait le
bilan un petit peu des mesures qui sont
annoncées en essayant de les traduire en
se posant la question qu'est ce que ça
va nous donner concrètement comme comme
peu de chose en plus si on fait le bilan
de ces mesures on se rend compte que
pour un hôpital qui est actuellement
déficitaire qui est un exercice
déficitaire de l'ordre de 4 millions
d'euros
l'ensemble de ces mesures nous permet de
maintenir notre déficit c'est à dire que
l'on va pas améliorer notre situation on
va éviter de la creuser et au prix d'une
activité qui va croissante
on parle de toujours sur des
augmentations d'activité pour voir plus
de financement est également au prix
d'un gel des postes médicaux et
soignants et technique d'ailleurs dans
l'hôpital donc en faisant des efforts le
plan annoncé nous permet tout juste de
maintenir un petit peu notre situation
actuelle et ne pas l'aggraver
merci philippe rousselot des revenus sur
notre plateau je le rappelle est chef de
service hématologie oncologie au centre
hospitalier de versailles
andré mignot
le point sur la réforme sur la grève
contre la réforme des retraites
maintenant si elle a tendance à faiblir
dans les transports après un mois et
demi de mobilisation d'autres
professions prennent le relais contre la
réforme des retraites plusieurs actions
ont lieu les 14 15 et 16 janvier dans
les yvelines cela a commencé dès mardi
avec les professionnels de santé de
l'hôpital mignot
le lendemain la plateforme industrielle
du courrier de bois d'arcy a été bloquée
très tôt dans la matinée par des
facteurs des cheminots ce qui a
fortement impacté la distribution même
jour à rambouillet un cortège de près de
200 personnes s'est rassemblée ils sont
partis de la caserne des pompiers et ont
fait le tour des services publics de la
ville les professeurs du lycée louis
basques ont occupé leurs établissements
toutes les demies en signe de
protestation aussi face à la réforme du
baccalauréat des enseignants aussi
devant le rectorat de l'académie de
versailles 200 professeurs ont
symboliquement vide et leurs cartables
jeudi des actions se sont déroulées
devant les mairies devait lisier de
meulan et devant le siège de la filiale
d'air france air et mahan et l'encours
la cgt cheminots de versailles réunis en
assemblée générale devant la gare des
chantiers a voté pour une nouvelle
reconduction du mouvement des conditions
de circulation dans les transports
restent donc perturbé consultez les
sites internet de la ratp de 30
étrangers bien pour vos trajets enfin
les avocats du barreau de versailles se
mobilise également depuis la semaine
dernière aucun avocat des désignés pour
les comparutions immédiates
ils ont voté ce lundi la reconduction de
ce mouvement jusqu'au 20 janvier compris
ils étaient rassemblés avec leurs
confrères d'autres départements devant
la cour d'appel de versailles ce
vendredi
réunion de crise le week-end dernier
pour le département il a annoncé rentrer
dans l'opposition face à l'entreprise
calcia celle ci soit déménagé son siège
social de rueil malmaison dans les hauts
de seine une trahison pour le président
du conseil départemental des yvelines
qui se désolidarise du projet des
explications par mathilde et demi
colère et trahisons pour pierre bédier
président du département des yvelines
il dénonce l'attitude de l'entreprise
calcia qui a annoncé la délocalisation
de son siège social dans les
hauts-de-seine sans en avertir le
département nous avons été trahis par
cette société et par des patrons voyous
qui au mépris de la parole donnée au
mépris des engagements pris et au mépris
des salariés de l'entreprise organise un
départ en catimini du territoire sur
lequel il ne laisserait que les
activités polluantes et tout ça pour
mener un plan social qui ne dit pas son
nom puisque à l'instant où je vous parle
on fait pression sur les salariés pour
les amener à démissionner puisque on les
déménage à plus de 30 km la société
calcia l'intention d'exploiter une
nouvelle carrière dans le vexin et
organise son départ vers rueil malmaison
un événement qui vient fragiliser
l'emploi local et qui attise
l'indignation des élus
en ce qui me concerne la confiance est
tout à fait rompu donc même si on a des
promesses avant le jeudi après midi
moi je rentre maintenant résolument dans
l'opposition acacias parce que ses
promesses même si elle arrive avant
jeudi
elles ne peuvent être que de papier ce
sont des promesses qui engage une
construction industrielle lourde qui
engagent des engagements sur la carrière
lourd et je pense que même si les
prennent pour deux ans pour trois ans
dont 3 en or a le même problème
la confiance est donc rompue pierre
bédier a annoncé qu'il demanderait jeudi
16 janvier une révision du plan local
d'urbanisme intercommunal pour interdire
à l'exploitation de la nouvelle carrière
à bruille en vexin
un ultimatum qui n'a pas reçu de réponse
de la part de calcia en conséquence la
communauté urbaine grand paris seine et
oise a voté ce jeudi une motion le but
inciter l'état à revenir sur
l'autorisation de carrière délivré à
l'entreprise
le département des yvelines va adopter
la même position lors de sa prochaine
séance plénière avoir une station
service dans sa poche grâce à son
smartphone c'est l'idée lancée il ya
deux ans par la société refoule située à
trappes
un service de livraison de carburant à
domicile proposés essentiellement aux
entreprises pour l'instant origins
quelques clics suffisent sur cette
application dédiée pour commander son
carburant depuis deux ans la société
refoule basée à trappes propose une
station-service ambulante dans les
yvelines ainsi que paris et sa petite
couronne
l'idée est partie d'une expérience
personnelle mon frère et moi nous étions
sur paris et puis un soir nous sommes
tombés en panne d'essence
voilà donc on s'est dit c'est tellement
simple aujourd'hui de se faire livrer
des pizzas de se faire livrer tout un
tas de choses
de là est né un début de projet on a
commencé à chercher vis-à-vis de la
législation des lois des autorisations
et ça nous a pris quatre ans aujourd'hui
l'entreprise d'une vingtaine de salariés
compte une cinquantaine de clients
essentiellement des entreprises la
société s'approvisionnent au dépôt
pétrolier de coignières la flotte est
pour l'instant composé d'une vingtaine
de véhicules
chaque camion un type de carburant
différents et peut transporter neuf cent
soixante litres comme aux est
géolocalisé vous avez le même tarif qu'à
la station service la plus proche
ensuite après nous on met notre notre
prix au service c'est aux alentours d'un
café un peu plus d'un café on osait
entre 2 2 euros 2 euros 50 refoule
propose également le gonflage des pneus
et le nettoyage des vitres objectifs
pour cette année 45 véhicules
supplémentaires
le recrutement d'une vingtaine de
salariés et l'élargissement de ce
service aux particuliers et grandes
agglomérations comme lure où bordeaux et
pour limiter votre consommation de
carburant pourquoi ne pas vous déplacer
à vélo le collectif vélos ile de france
a justement dévoilé la carte de son
projet le rer v13 express régional vélo
autrement dit relier l'ensemble de l'île
de france grâce à un réseau de pistes
cyclables
cauet roman et surtout interconnecté
neuf lignes en tout qui pourrait
permettre de se rendre facilement par
exemple à versailles et vélizy ou sans
nom la bretèche depuis un an ce sont 33
associations qui travaillent sur ce
projet chiffré à 500 millions d'euros du
vélo à la course à pied avec laquelle on
ouvre une large page sportive l'eco
trail de paris fête cette année sa 13e
édition l'épreuve sera organisée au mois
de mars
elle relie chaque année les yvelines au
premier étage de la tour eiffel
au programme cinq distances dont 1 80 km
au départ de lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
la conférence de presse de présentation
était organisée jeudi 7 janvier
nicolas landry et michael et minéraux
étaient sur place l'eco trail de paris
l'une des courses les plus importantes
en ile de france cette année quatorze
mille personnes se sont inscrites pour
l'épreuve
la conférence de presse avait lieu au
premier étage de la tour eiffel
[Musique]
cette année les qautre elle proposera
cinq formats les distances 10 18 30 45
et 1 80 km au départ de lille de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines 80 km c'est
beaucoup
c'est un parcours qui est quand même
assez exigeant on parle de du domaine de
l'île loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines avec 1 21 étoiles et des des
parcours qui passe par buqueux
versailles et autres cette exigence est
démonté ces des descentes c'est des
changements de rythme et c'est de la
distance ont beaucoup ifo l'entraînement
il y aura une touche de glamour sur
cette eco trail quatre miss france vont
gravir les marches de la tour eiffel
pour l'association les bonnes fées cette
année nous avons veille malama chavez
maeva cook et marie l'orphelin et une 4e
encore qui est en train de se motiver
franchement c'est bon enfant on le fait
vraiment pour notre association
grâce à l'argent qu'on va pouvoir
récolter cette année on va pouvoir
financer 150 et craint des faits sont
des sacs qu'on distribue dans des
maternités à des femmes dans le besoin
la course comprend également plusieurs
partenaires dont le département des
yvelines
les deux épreuves principales de cette
du 45 et du 80 km par taddei vinh
respectivement du château de versailles
et de la base de saint quentin
en yvelines et puis aussi parce qu'il ya
les valeurs partagées avec l'eco trail
concernant le domaine du développement
durable la 13ème édition de l'eco trail
ce sera donc le 14 mars prochain départ
depuis l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines information insolite le club
de football paris saint-germain lançons
jus de poire artisanale les fruits
seront 100% yvelinois et proviendront de
deux vergers installé sur le futur
centre d'entraînement du club à poissy
au total de 1800 poirier de sept
variétés différentes seront implantés
mille bouteilles seront servis jusqu'à
la fin de la saison aux spectateurs des
espaces hospitalité au parc des princes
l'équipe de football américain locales
les templiers d'elancourt redémarre pour
une nouvelle saison
ils jouent ce week-end dans le
championnat de 2e division contre les
léopards de rouen quatre mois de
préparation durant lesquels ils ont mis
en place attaque et défense avec des
entraînements et des matches amicaux
face à des équipes de division
supérieure
on écoute le coach de l'équipe qui
étaient en plateau du 7-8 sport on a
donné
michael une grande dimension sur la
partie formation que ce soit la
formation évidemment des joueurs et
l'accompagnement des joueurs évidemment
dans la construction si des cheerleaders
avec la création d'une section junior et
puis la formation des arbitres toute la
partie encadrement en fait une structure
forte en fait sur la partie
d'encadrement et un effort particulier
en fait sur la formation avec
l'accompagnement évidemment de joueurs
seniors qui viennent renforcer en fait
les dispositifs pour transmettre le
savoir c'est finalement une des valeurs
des templiers n'étant billets
d'elancourt qui avait disputé une finale
européenne à domicile en 2005 c'est
votre rubrique ça s'est passé
[Musique]
éliminé en demi finale du championnat
français de 1re division les templiers
entendez bien finir la saison avec pour
mot une coupe entre les mains seulement
l'homme fort de l'équipe pérez mathieson
montreux dès le début des signes de
faiblesse le quarterback américain peine
à trouver ses marques sur une pelouse
détrempée par un orage survenu plus tôt
dans l'après-midi une opportunité vite
saisi par les mercenaires qui inscrit de
quatre minutes plus tard quand premier
touchdown grâce à jérôme castle berry
aussitôt transformé au pied par peter
muller comme tout au long de la
rencontre les allemands progressent
ensuite égard par yard sans qu'aucune
intervention efficace des templiers les
frêles si bien que le numéro 7 trouve
une nouvelle fois le chemin de l'en but
adverse
le break est ensuite définitivement
acquis grâce à se lancer de 40 hier
de second quart temps dépassé en défense
les templiers vont finalement reprendre
goût à l'attaqué grâce à thérèse
mathieson que l'on retrouve ici plus
inspiré après avoir rapproché les siens
à deux gardes de la endzone il inscrit
ses premiers points
on est malgré une nouvelle action juste
avant la mi temps le score est déjà de
14 à 35
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous avez dit à la
mi-temps de rester ensemble
si on n'y croit plus dira bien
un conseil simple qui finalement ne paye
pas si l'on en croit la dispersion de la
défense sur cet essai allemand on
retiendra tout de même côté templiers
cette course de 15 yards de jérémy là je
pense qu on a fait trop d'erreurs en
défense mais a raté des plaquages à des
moments clés ils ont pas eu vraiment de
gros jeux il y un an s'est petit à petit
et c'est là qu'on va pas réussi à les
arrêter quand on a eu des occasions les
arrêtés on les a pas saisies ont raté
quelques plaquages on a tous fait des
erreurs les uns après les autres
moi le premier première participation en
finale de la fa cup
c'est une très belle saison mais on joue
pas pour perdre donc on voulait gagner
or les ossements de ce qu'on peut penser
qu actuellement vu le nombre de joueurs
vu le gabarit des joueurs les vraiment
summum bêtise ça viendra plus tard
[Musique]
elle a ouvert ses portes en mai 2003 à
voisins le bretonneux la librairie
lettres voisine à l'aune de sa majorité
s'apprête à fermer les onze mille
ouvrages prennent place dans les cartons
à défaut de trouver un repreneur point
finale prévue le 31 janvier
sa gérante christine sauvage regrette la
fin de ce commerce culturel de proximité
qui ne parvient plus à résister aux
grands groupes et à la vente en ligne
même avec notre syndicat des libraires
de france on n'a pas la force l'impact
nécessaire pour faire face à ce genre de
deux concurrents je regrette vraiment
pour voisin que cette librairie ferme
parce que pendant longtemps on a cru que
ça allait continuer et que d'autres
prennent le relais le théâtre investi
l'espace albert camus durant trois
semaines à maurepas
pour la cinquième édition du festival
plein feux sur les planches qui met le
théâtre amateur l'honneur quatre troupes
participent six thèmes tandem la classe
la claque et la troupe du crâne
l'occasion pour eux de présenter leur
spectacle de manière professionnelle
on leur propose une résidence d'une
semaine avec on leur met à disposition
les moyens techniques de la salle
des avis de professionnel de manière à
peaufiner leur spectacle et donc elle
sera en fin de semaine elle se présente
au mourre patients et à ceux qui veulent
venir
[Musique]
on mélange cultures et modes les 25 et
26 janvier à paris avec le snec heures
ce mythe premier événement entièrement
dédié à la basket et sa culture
au programme un programme chargé autour
du thème les baskets de la rue au grand
écran reportage de nos confrères fille
la grande part et la sneakers c'est bien
plus qu'une simple paire de baskets
autour de ces chaussures s'est créé une
véritable culture qui mélange le sport
les arts la musique ou encore la mode en
janvier 2020 le sneakers mythe réunir un
pari tous les passionnés de ce mouvement
et se rend compte qu'elle a basket en
fait et transversales et notre objectif
c'est une montre un petit peu au grand
public celui qui porte de la basket et
qui adore ça de lui montrer que derrière
chaque modèle vous avez des histoires et
des anecdotes qui sont intéressantes à
raconter
le premier sneakers mythe aura pour
thème les baskets de la rue au grand
écran ou comment sneakers et cinéma ont
toujours fait bon ménage
mais identifier une vingtaine de films
et de séries qui ont marqué les années
90 et la culture urbaine
on peut raconter des anecdotes très
drôle autour de forrest gump par exemple
autour de big autour de kill bill ou on
retrouve une paire de onitsuka tiger
mais est ce que vous saviez que batman
portaient des sneakers dans la première
édition du film comme 1989
au programme deux jours d'événements
pour les accros de la sneakers mais
aussi pour les passionnés de culture
urbaine et de sport on va avoir une
sélection des meilleurs créateurs et des
meilleures tendances et des meilleurs
revendeurs de sneakers
vous allez également trouvé un skate
park qui nous est prêtée et mise à dispo
par la mairie de paris
vous allez pouvoir retrouver surtout une
bonne salle de cinéma qui va être
reproduite dans lesquelles il va y avoir
des conférences la diffusion d'une web
série
la première édition du sneakers au mythe
aura lieu les 25 et 26 janvier où paris
events center de la porte de la villette
et vous démontrera que la basket est
passé en quelques décennies du produit
de grande consommation au phénomène
culturel
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis et beau week-end sur
tv 78
[Musique]
m